revista de prensa en directo américa de
france a 24 ya rosa pérez más le gustaba
conmigo en el estudio de rosa bienvenida
feliz mañana de viernes vamos a abrir
esta sección del día de hoy con la
portada de esta semana de the economist
super impactante pues haciendo alusión a
toda esta destrucción planetaria que
estamos haciendo nosotros como humanidad
buenos días raúl exactamente no con el
titular la catástrofe alimentaria que se
avecina díaz economista publica esta
imagen donde vemos espigas de trigo
donde los granos son de hecho calaveras
cuando nos acercamos un poco a la imagen
un diseño gráfico que ha sido muy
aplaudido precisamente porque pues
sobran las palabras el mensaje es muy
directo aún así evidentemente esta
portada de esta semana de díaz
economista va acompañada por un artículo
que empieza de la siguiente manera al
invadir ucrania vladímir putin también
destruirá la vida de las personas que se
encuentran lejos del campo de batalla y
en una escala que incluso él puede
lamentar no esté en que incluso el puede
lamentar un poco marca de la casa de
díaz economist un medio pues liberal que
no pierde ocasión de atacar duramente a
vladimir putin pero lo cierto es que
desde el principio de esta invasión rusa
de ucrania pues se habló de las
consecuencias sobre el sistema mundial
de alimentos que tendría pues sobre todo
por la producción y exportación de trigo
no dado que tanto rusia como ucrania son
de los principales productores y
exportadores mundiales de este alimento
y que de hecho para muchos países de
áfrica y de asia pues depende el consumo
de las importaciones que vienen de rusia
y ucrania como es el caso por ejemplo de
egipto y de indonesia de hecho nos da el
dato que rusia y ucrania en términos de
calorías suministran el 12 por ciento de
las calorías comercializadas a nivel
mundial no las calorías en referencia a
esta energía que absorbemos de los
alimentos y por otro lado los precios
del trigo subieron un 53 por ciento
desde principios de año y aumentaron
otros 6% particularmente el 16 de mayo
cuando india anunció que suspendía
también las exportaciones debido a la
extrema de calor que atraviesa ese país
y pues otras cifras pues también muy
alarmantes y es que 1.600 millones de
personas a nivel mundial se encuentran
en situación de inseguridad alimentaria
y casi 250 millones de personas están al
borde de la hambruna un escenario pues
que va en vistas de agravarse pues a
medida que se alargue también esta
guerra pues en ucrania y defiende este
artículo de the economist con esta
portada pues que no somos conscientes un
poco de lo que nos viene que solamente
el aumento del costo de la vida es una
primera señal de un panorama que puede
agravarse bastante incluso ya está bien
agravado este panorama en algunos de los
países africanos como usted bien los
apuntaba rosa cambiamos de tema porque
recuperamos un texto el investigador
arsenio cuenca que pues precisamente va
a ser en nuestro primer invitado del día
con él vamos a conversar más adelante él
hizo el publicó este texto en el orden
mundial en relación con el manifiesto
atribuido al presunto asesino de búfalo
en nueva york en eeuu donde rechaza la
pornografía y la masturbación cuál es
esa relación entre la postura y también
los postulados de extrema derecha rosa
en raúl pues este investigador como
decías publicó este artículo pero de
hecho en 2021 pero les recuperamos ahora
porque es importante pues
estudiante exacto no la relación entre
estos postulados puede ser de rechazo
pues la pornografía o la masturbación
con las ideologías de extrema derecha
de hecho arsenio cuenca estudia la
radicalización de la extrema derecha en
internet y cuenta que hay espacios
virtuales aparentemente inofensivos que
son una puerta de entrada finalmente
pues a las ideologías neofascistas de
hecho habla de videojuegos de páginas de
anime o páginas incluso de fitness y
superación personal y aquí vamos dice
cada vez más jóvenes confusos con sus
hábitos sexuales se ven expuestos a
contenidos en apariencia a políticos e
inofensivos que pueden ser la puerta de
entrada a ideologías radicales así surge
la figura de los coach o entrenadores de
seducción y demás influencers que dan
consejos para encarar su sexualidad o
encontrar pareja entre las consignas hay
una a la que en varios de ellos dejar el
porno y la masturbación porque dan por
hecho de hecho sin ningún tipo de
fundamento c's que la abstinencia
aumenta los niveles de testosterona y de
aquí a la revitalización de la
masculinidad como parte de la
revitalización de la ocde la sociedad
occidental supuestamente en la
decadencia y bueno una serie de
argumentos pues como decíamos sin ningún
tipo de fundamento científico que abren
la puerta pues a la radicalización de
extrema derecha y a la supremacía blanca
rosa y también otro tema que se vuelve a
debatir después de cada masacre en eeuu
es el control de armas en este país tras
la matanza de búfalo como lo estábamos
hablando anteriormente la revista faith
the value recuperó la serie fotográfica
americans exacto 15 v dobles a raíz de
este pues de esta masacre de racista en
buffalo recuperó esta serie fotográfica
de gabriel galimberti que se publicó en
el national geographic pero que ganó
después el premio en la categoría de
retrato en el world press photo donde
vemos a parte del normalidad con la que
posan estas personas estadounidenses
frente a frente a su arsenal
armamentístico pues se ve reflejado un
poco los siguientes datos y es que según
el small arms survey la mitad de las
armas de fuego que poseen los ciudadanos
a nivel privado se encuentran en los
eeuu donde de hecho hay más armas en
circulación en términos privados que no
pues habitantes no hay 393 millones de
armas para unos 330 millones de
habitantes rosas gracias que eso con
nosotros para conversar con nuestro
primer mitad del día